and we begin in lebanon where mustafa
adib has just been named as prime
minister designate and tasked with
forming a new government
the ambassador to germany won support
from several parties including
the future movement and the shia bloc
hezbollah
there is no room for words or promises
it's time for us to join hands
and restore hope among lebanese all
lebanese are pinning high hopes on this
and we hope we will be successful we
want to restore hope
and get back on our feet to work for the
benefit of our country
i have accepted this task because i'm
aware and all the political factions are
aware
of the gravity of the situation and the
necessity
to immediately implement reforms okay
let's bring in zina
who's live for us in beirut uh zaina why
was it that most of our adid
managed to garner so much support
well there are two reasons yesterday he
emerged as a consensus candidate the
different political factions from across
lebanon's divided political landscape
they agreed that this is the man who is
going to head
the next government but what we
understand is that there was a lot of
pressure from behind the scenes
france a main power broker in this
ongoing political crisis in lebanon
trying and persuading lebanese
politicians to move ahead to form a
government that is ready
to carry out much-needed reforms to
unlock aid and to
reach a bailout plan with the
international monetary
fund we heard mustafa hadib say the
right things he's promising
a swift formation of a government he's
promising to carry out reforms he's even
saying that his cabinet is
going to be made up of experts we heard
that from the previous prime minister
hassan died when he took office
a few months ago but this time around
yes both these men hassan
mustafa they have been appointed by the
political establishment an establishment
which has governing this country for
decades
an establishment many people do not have
faith in but unlike hassan died
he has the support of the majority of
the parliamentarians and
unlike hassan dieb he seems to have the
support of the international community
which could make it easier for him to
push ahead with much needed reforms
and zeno of course it doesn't matter
essentially who gets into the prime
minister's slot the problems that
lebanon is facing
remain the same and it's an uphill
battle from here
a lot of challenges this country was
close to collapse
before the august 4 beirut port
explosion which destroyed and damaged
many neighborhoods in the lebanese
capital
billions of dollars are needed to
rebuild the homes and people's lives
before that the economy has been run to
the ground
the currency the exchange rate has
plummeted the price of food
rising unemployment is rising according
to the united nations
55 of the population of 5 million people
live below the poverty line those in
power the political establishment are
being blamed for years of corruption
and mismanagement and that's why the
international community is telling them
there will be no blank checks you have
to agree on reforms
you have to fight corruption or else
you're not getting the money
so at the end it seems that those in
power realize that this
is their last chance and they may at
least cooperate
more than they were uh intending to do
in the first place
xena thanks very much that's zina
hodolai for us in beirut